ron's parliament is calling for quote
proportional and reciprocal action in
response to the US withdrawal from a
deal halting Iran's nuclear program
president Trump fulfilled a campaign
promise yesterday declaring the u.s. is
leaving the deal he said quote we cannot
prevent an Iranian nuclear bomb under
the decaying and rotten structure of the
current agreement a memo signed by the
president reinstates many sanctions that
were lifted back in 2015 the
organization overseeing inspections
inside Iran confirmed this morning Iran
is still obeying the terms of the deal
the Elizabeth Palmer's in Tehran with
more reaction on this Elizabeth good
morning to you good morning certainly
for the people of Iran and the
government of president Hassan rouhani
the u.s. pull out from the nuclear deal
is a devastating blow and already we can
see the hardliners maneuvering to take
advantage of it conservative lawmakers
this morning burned a paper US flag in
the parliament and chanted the familiar
death to America president rouhani who
staked his reputation on the benefits of
the deal told the world last night it is
not dead and he will continue to work
with the other five countries still
committed to saving the deal but there's
no question it's under huge strain and
so are the people who are already
squeezed by a weak economy here and
everyone is worried about the return of
top US sanctions Iran's supreme leader
Ali Khamenei said this morning that the
President's speech had been silly and
superficial and had contained 10 lies he
ended by saying you have made a mistake
Trump Norah all right Elizabeth Palmer
in Tehran thank you